the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
while people trickle in this this this
slide is my attempt to summarize what we
said last time or you said last time
mostly so it's it's basically the movie
is making a case for microfinance and
the case is all these different points
or they're building a case for a
particular version of microfinance and
and they're making this this set of
points they start with the point that
poor have poor access to credit that
they're reliable borrowers that that may
be group lending has something to do
with the reliability that microfinance
can lift people out of poverty the way
does it is through new businesses and
that input and the fact that this is
these new businesses generate increased
earnings of women has the implication
that there is then greater investment in
human capital so and finally there is an
implied but also I think important claim
that there's no conflict between so the
commercialization of microcredit and an
emphasis on its social role so those are
the claims being made so what I want to
do today is mostly kind of go through
the thinking behind all what the
argument behind each of these and then
try to look at the data of it so this is
this is a tell you a little bit about an
evaluation we did of a program of an
organ circle Spandana very traditional
program the group liability must be
weekly payment starting loan is about
ten thousand rupees
interest rate was about twelve percent
twenty four percent per year really they
way they calculate is funny so it's
twenty
percent per year it was a very large MF
ie already but it had not entered the
city called Hyderabad it was so what we
the deal we had with them was they were
going to enter the city of Hyderabad but
not everywhere they're going to enter
out of 104 neighborhoods we selected
poor neighborhoods we selected they they
gonna enter 52 and they'll keep the
other 52 for 18 months untouched
that was the deal so that's the sperm
donor group we surveyed so this data is
from 7,200 people who we surveyed
72 for households these households were
selected based on the fact that it will
be eligible for a loan
there's no I'm not interesting to
compare people you could have also done
something else but it makes sense to
select people now we didn't select them
just in the places where it's good
microcredit because we wanted to compare
the places which got my cover and which
didn't so we had equal numbers of people
where 3,600 people with these
characteristics in where they got the
loan and 3,600 people with this car's
characteristics which who didn't get the
loan basic idea is to compare people who
could have got a loan if they had been
in microfinance organization in their
neighborhood with people who did get a
loan these people are relatively poor
they were bought a monthly expenditure
family of five monthly expenditure over
$125 most most of their children and
going to school though they do borrow
one day boy many of them have loans when
they borrow a 69% of the households have
loans but a lot of the households that
have loans from moneylenders pay about 4
percent per month so so spon general
charges
24% per year which is less than 2% I
want to is that's called a simple
interest 2% a month
simple interest which is less than is
substantially less than half of that
there's no MFI borrowing at the
beginning lots of them run businesses
31% that's a number to note because you
take the rich country average the rich
country average is something like 12
percent 9 percent run more than one
business but these businesses are
extremely basic like I have a shop I
have in the shop I have bottles in the
big bottles with cookies matchboxes
cigarettes and candy in them
that's my shop I sell that or I have a
little push cart and I sell vegetables
on it so these very businesses are not
high skill they are very little capital
and have no employees the profits are
about $75 a month so very small
businesses like like those when we ask
them in the beginning why do you want to
get a loan a lot of them said what you
had already anticipated you might want
to get a loan not just to start a
business but also to repay a loan to do
something for your household to buy a
fridge or or a TV so they were quite
candid about the fact that they didn't
necessarily want to start a business so
skip that so before we get into the
results it's worth thinking a little bit
about what we should expect to see and
in particular should we expect people on
average to be consuming more when they
get a lot yes No
antis antis yeah yeah okay explain if
they
yeah
you might think that a lot of might go
down as a result of starting a business
because right now I'm studying a
business I don't want to start into the
smallest possible skill I might want to
buy some inputs for my business expand
it so I might want to start a business I
might actually want to cut back on
consumption for a while before I go back
to you know over time it should go back
up but at the beginning I might very
well see a fall in consumption so that's
that's an important thing to keep in
mind that if people are starting
businesses then they may not actually
you know they may actually cut back so
you may not see a big net increase you
will see an increase if they start the
business and business successful then
you know two years later you'll see an
increase but not right away so here's
the first problem we had in this
evaluation which is that despite the
fact that Spandana said they would not
enter these neighborhoods that were put
into control the loan officers did why
because they thought well that's a goal
that looks like a nice neighborhood we
could lend more to people and make more
money so they went in and we had to kind
of fight a lot to stop them and so in
the end the difference we're in sponder
Alone's was only 13 percent should have
been bigger now we because that happened
so some of the control neighborhoods got
this the loans we're not going to be
using we're not going to be using the
actual fact of who got alone and who won
who didn't get alone we're going to use
the intention-to-treat will will compare
places that we thought should not have a
loan with places which we thought should
have a loan that's something that was
this determined by randomizing where as
who actually got alone was not random I
would go into the most you know when I
when the people went into control
neighborhoods they went into the best
you know most most attractive ones so we
can't do that we need to compare ones
which were actually which actually got
the Lord
and even worse than that we're spawning
I didn't go other ramifies went because
they wanted to fill up the market so
this difference is small so when you see
that why is that relevant well when you
see the difference I'm going to show you
the average difference between places
that were intended to get I'll intended
to get a micro farad finance with places
that were not intended to get my room
financed notice that that difference is
only 8% the the places that were
intended to get microfinance are only 8%
people there are only 8 percent more
likely to have a loan in places that
we're intended not to get microfinance
so when I look at the average of those
places or do what what should I do to
get what will happen to the magnitude of
the effect it'll be very small because
only 8% difference you know in either
both places a lot of people got loans so
the difference was small to two so to
get the real sense of the magnitude of
the effect I need to multiply by since
it's 8 percent of the people generated
this difference to get the full effect
of this what should I do
to get a sense of the magnitude of it
what would I need is 8 percent generate
an effect of 5 what would have only
effect have been in 100 percentage the
difference for Sunday's
you multiply 100 divided by 12
so you'll do something like that so when
you look at a number that will look
small but you really have to realize
that that's a difference generated by
the difference is generated by a very
small difference in take-up so these
results are look much smaller than they
really are so here's what happened in in
the business space there's some increase
in new businesses which was significant
some increase in profits which is not
significant some increase in revenues
which was not significant but the the
new business was significant
you get about so think of it this way
this is the number of businesses set up
in one and a half years so basically 31
percent already had a business and
another 7 percent set up businesses in
the treatment and 5.3 percent set up
business in the control so that's like
if you like a 30 percent increase in the
number of new businesses so it's not
small it's you look small numbers but
it's in fact it's a significant increase
you know you went this in any case
people don't start that many new
businesses so this is not a it was there
was some effect consumption blue is
always controlled yellow is a treatment
so consumption didn't really go up
significantly but we kind of discussed
why that might happen you do see more
durable purchases more business durable
purchases and I won't say what
temptation goods are right now okay so
less temptation was but you do see more
business here's what didn't happen
despite the gendered nature of spending
apparently nothing changed so schooling
is hard to change because everybody goes
to school so let's say that's difficult
to change but nothing else change either
children were just as unhealthy women
were no more likely to have decision
power on spending in the household and
expenditures didn't go up so if you
think that you know women spend
differently we didn't find any evidence
of it so there was no the gender effect
that we had sort of discussed doesn't
seem to be in this data the next thing
we did is go back to that story we were
telling we were telling a story where
some people would invest start a new
business and they will cut their
consumption others will grow there
others will not start their business and
now they might they have no reason to
cut their consumption so imagine that
the two kinds of people one kind of
people are going to start a new business
and the other kind won't so what we want
to do is we want to predict who those
people are we don't want to so if we
went to the treatment areas and we
looked at who started a new business and
we went to the control areas when we
looked at who started a new business and
you compare them would there be a valid
comparison
and we repeat the question suppose I go
into the treatment areas and I to
treatment it is in the control of a
randomly chosen I went to the treatment
areas I found people there who had
started a business I went to the control
areas and I found people who had already
started a business and newly started a
business and I compared them would that
be a valid comparison
so when I say newly started a business
these are people who started a business
in the eighteen months when we were
observing why did the reason why is
because while you are carrying
businesses started in the
due to the fact that they got the bomb
versus just do the place I mean yeah you
cook Americans malaria but even your
control versus your treatment areas on
the Senate e-ticket
so basically you
I think it's that's not quite right I
think you don't never want to do it you
reason you never want to do it is
because you don't do actually what you
think of people who start a business
when I come and offer them alone versus
people who start a business when no
loans were available or less loans were
available and there different kinds of
people I
when loan is easy to get i I might start
a business with loans are difficult to
get I'm lazy I won't start a business
where somebody who starts alone when
loans are not easily available is
probably much more committed to starting
a business is much more incentivized so
you don't want to compare them so what
we had to do we had to think of who what
could predict who would start a business
then what we could do is you could split
we could look for to see the kind of
people who start a business in treatment
and look for the same kind of people in
control so we could we could have a
predicted model of who would start a
business we could compare the things
that predict whether you start a
business or not okay so we want to
divide the population based on fixed
characteristics and the fixed
characteristic that work very well is if
you own land and if you have a typically
a wife a woman in the household was
literate and doesn't work so if you have
some assets you have a there's a woman
in the household who is currently not
working but she has silt skills she's
literate she's actually a prime
candidate for starting a business so it
turns out that if you look for family
families with these characteristics in
treatment and control there were equal
numbers of families in treatment control
not accidentally I mean that's how you'd
expect you'd expect randomly chosen so
they are about the same so you take
those two kinds of families to these
kinds of families which are available to
it rent control the identical yeah
this is not an instrument of variable
it's just predicting who you are going
to start a business then what I'm going
to do is I'm going to create a I'm going
to eat this is like baseline
characteristics they're just different
people I can estimate the treatment
effect for any subset of people like I
could say what's the effect on tall
people right this is just take a subset
of the population who are with these
characteristics that predict a business
those people do I get in those people's
consumption does it behave differently
from the consumption of everyone else
that's the question I'm asking if these
are people whose characteristics predict
that they will start a business do they
behave differently from everybody else
whose characteristics predict that they
won't start a business so the three
groups and we look at people who are
going to start whose characteristics
predict they will start a business
people who already have a business and
people who have neither have a business
nor will start a business so that's what
I'm trying to and if you do it you do
see the difference the in the treatment
the people who are who we predict should
start a business are much more likely to
start a business the people who predict
and shouldn't start a business actually
slightly less like those other business
so that's that sort of what you'd expect
and now you start to see much bigger
differences so the people who who start
a business and people already had a
business expand their businesses or they
they buy durables the people who didn't
have a business and don't are not
planning a business so durables can
include for example business assets they
can build their they can repair the
house where they're going to have a shop
so all those things are durables so they
seem to do stuff that could be related
to the business the people who we
predict should not start a business
don't start a business and they don't
make any durable expenditures they
increase non-durable expenditures a lot
so the bottom group
increases non-durable expenditures
that's like spending on food and things
like that the top groups the middle
group basically nothing changes and the
top group cuts non-durable they're
eating less these people are spending
less on food they're buying more durable
the durables are what they want for the
future so they seem to be behaving in
very different ways so what finally this
this thing of temptation boots what our
temptation goods well we asked people
this is a betelnut seller be a beetle
nuts beetle leaf seller Sophie people in
South Asia and Southeast Asia chew these
leaves and these nuts which are called
beetle nuts and beetle leaves they have
slightly narcotic effects mild narcotic
effects a lot of people chew them and
this guy's a vendor he's a small
business owner so we asked people in the
base line to tell us what are things you
want to give up on spending so we asked
them to give us a list of things they
said they'll give up on spare they want
to give up and that that was basically
very simple they want to give up on tea
coffee snacks beetle nuts cigarettes and
alcohol that's that's all they wanted
these were the things they want to give
up now we go back to years later look at
the data and we classify spending on
these things versus everything else
these things we call temptation because
there's things that they say they don't
want to do what they end up spending and
what you see quite dramatically is that
that's where you see a big difference
the people who are starting a business
cut back massively in their spending on
temptation goods the people who are who
will never start a business seem to have
seemed to be having a party they go out
and they start spending
or on those things so basically what's
going on for many of these people is
they're turning their Temptation
expenditures they're using that money to
pay the loan you know the loan payment
and then with the money they're buying
something else so they when they get the
money they either by abusing durable or
a business durable they expand their
their consumption their durable
ownership and then they pay down by
cutting back on their temptation goods
so they're they're drinking less tea and
the owning more TVs if you like yeah
because these people are starting a
business they need the money
no they're much less likely remember
this is these people have high
propensity to start a business
nevertheless in control they're much
less like to do ever only half as likely
to start a business in control as in
treatment so these people are much more
likely to be people who started
businesses in treatment
okay so that's sort of the now this is a
story which is kind of blasted you it
depends on the so when we publish these
results the reaction from the
microfinance industry was very negative
largely they did they thought these
results were showing that they had
failed and they really went ballistic I
mean you know there was lots and lots of
blogs which explain how we don't
understand how to under analyze
microcredit and people made you know the
they were like many and the World Bank's
website they were like dismissive
statements and all that so there are
lots of these things basically claiming
that you know microcredit is too subtle
to be analyzed by us so why was the
reaction we we actually didn't think
that this was so negative in fact we
thought this was fine you know they knew
bases are went up the people we thought
would do better we're doing better some
people were doing worse that's normal
like you know say give people alone not
everybody is going to use it well some
people are going to use it in ways that
will get them into trouble others are
going to have a great use it very well
and do well out of it you're always
creating some risk when you create
financial products we but you know
people really hate hated these results
and so we got some pushback then went
away for the in a kind of a sad way what
happened next was that so this was going
on through 2008-2009 when our results
came out there was lots of kind of push
back and then side by side with that
something else started happening and
that's sort of unfortunate so just be so
the next thing that happened was that in
2009 and I guess in both in 2009 once
again what an organizer for Compartamos
in Mexico had an an IPO you know what
IPO is
an initial public offering they sold
their stock and they made a ton of money
and our religion called SKS in India
which we actually worked with on
something else not microcredit then went
ahead and they had another IPO these
IPOs raised a lot of money like hundreds
of millions of dollars and the reaction
to that was correctly this means these
organizations are very profitable all
the suddenly everybody got upset with
them because they realized that if they
if these companies can be sold for three
hundred billion dollars then they must
be making a lot of money now that's a
bit unfair because they were making a
lot of money but they also had lots of
clients you know if you have three
million clients then making 300 million
dollars over over the next 20 years or
something is not so much after after all
it's not that much money if you think of
it you know I'm making yeah I've seen
million plans I'm making 300 million
dollars that's 100 million dollars
hundred dollars per client over the next
let's say ten years so that's ten
dollars per year per client which is not
nearly as profitable as it sounds when
you say it's 300 billion dollars because
these are big organizations and many of
them are so in any case that got them
into lots of trouble so everybody so
first thing that happened was that a lot
of microfinance people started getting
very upset Muhammad Yunus who started
the mean Bank was really the him and he
called them the new users and basically
said that this sort of this commercial
is kind of commercialization of
microfinance this goes against the
spirit of microfinance so that was
already trouble because there was
divided in the community what happened
after that was even so they said yeah we
have a minute so
they said but that you know what we're
trying to do we're doing an IPO because
this is the best way to raise capital
and we raise capital we get a lot we
have a lot of equity we can now go and
borrow a lot based on our equity and
then we can expand lending so instead of
you know 30 10 million people hundred
million people can get loans so they
were they were making the case like in
the movie that we really need to go in
this direction so this was a fight going
on then what happened this is goes into
the beginning of 2010 now so the these
two fights going on through 2009 one is
basically against us and another set of
results by Dean Colin who's at Yale also
showing small positive results but the
microfinance community didn't like the
small positive results and they didn't
like this these IPOs then what happened
is that a number of people committed
suicide number of people in in India in
in one state of India which is called
under Pradesh this committed suicide
some of them claiming that this because
their loan burden was too high
turned out that they had borrowed from
seven six or seven different
microfinance organizations and they
couldn't repay and they committed
suicide and at that point these all
these forces kind of you know lined up
in exactly the worst possible way for
the industry first there were these
suicides second was a fight within the
industry and third there were these
results showing that they hadn't done
something so great and the net result
was that there was an attempt to
basically a political you know there was
a political attempt to shut down
microcredit and that's still continuing
in a sense and I what I want to end on
is showing you a video which is
so BBC is you saw a video that was very
Pro microcredit I want to show you a
video that's more more recent and much
less Pro microcredit where is it
so you can see
you can have unfair views on any side
you want you can make that's that's
that's a hatchet job so main point being
that I think that I only want to end on
this one point which is that if you look
at this study it is exactly almost the
same job of you know very similar it's
rhetorical strategy very similar I go to
some person in some village in something
bad happened that means that this thing
is bad you just look for the people and
in some ways I think this has been the
industry's problem and you the reason
why that guy got nailed so badly is
because you know instead of saying that
here this is something that's useful and
we we should find out how useful it is
this started by over selling and then
it's their easy target everybody now is
it's like well if you over sell people
have high expectations then you don't
deliver they get very upset with you and
so that's what they're paying for now
and sort of this is like you know this
is exactly what you'd expect the reason
why we were trying to persuade them for
at least seven eight years that they
should have a randomized evaluation and
we won I remember going to an MFI and
explaining that they should have a
randomized evaluation they should show
that they have evidence of the impact
and the guy told me he was an
interesting character he was a Canadian
who had started an MFI in rural India
and he was very very I mean he was
clearly not doing this because he was
like you know making more money that way
it was dedicated to the cause and he
this was he was living in rural India
lending people were buying cows so it's
not but you know he basically got so
upset with the idea he said you know you
when you buy an Apple you don't look at
the evaluation of that people are buying
credit we are selling it what's wrong
with that and so he just threw a sort of
as a of his office basically but I think
that's their problem their problem came
from
the beginning they just kind of push
back on any possibility that you know
you want to make a kind of a reasoned
take a recent view of these things and
then in some ways that creates the
problem yeah